لاني ما ابغى اتكلم عن مواضيع الانسانيه
او مواضيع الاخلاقيه لانه ما لها معنى لن
تغير في في نظام الناس العاده صعب انك
تغيرها لذلك انك تتكلم مع الناس ان غير
عدد غير عددك عشان الاخلاق غير عادتك عشان
البيئه غير عادتك عشان الصحن التوي كذا
وماله فايده
الوالد الانضباط تعلمت فنون الاستثمار
وش اللي سلمته من الوالده الله يرحمها
من الوالده
لسه
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح تخيل انت تفطر بدون سمبوسه شوربه
بدون لحم تتسحر على حمص هذا في رمضان طيب
رمضان نفس الشيء ما تاكل لحم لعب برجر لا
شاورما المفطح
وما تشرب حليب ولا لبن وتوقع واضحين رايح
تخيل تكون نباتي يا حياه الشقه لكن في
جانب مهم ورائع في كل شخص نباتي هو انه
شخص منضبط الانضباط والالتزام في الحياه
احد اهم اسباب النجاح بل لو كان في سبب
للنجاح فهو حتى من الالتزام يتفوق على
الموهبه وعلى الحظ وعلى الذكاء كيف اثر
الانضباط على الصحه على العمل كيف تتمرن
يوميا بدايه كل صباح دونك كلل او ملل كيف
تشتغل في وضفت وظيف تين حتى التاسعه ليلا
كل يوم يقول ضيفي ان الشغف مهم لكن ممكن
تفقده في مرحله او فتره فلا تركن للشغف
لصناعه مجد لكن الالتزام هو اللي يخليه
يصحى الساعه ثلاثه الفجر
عشان يتمرن ضيفي لا يحتاج للعمل لاجل
المال فودي اعرف ايش اللي يدفعه على كل
هذا ضيفي هو الامير خالد بن الوليد بن
طلال مؤسس ورئيس
للاستثمار ورئيس الاتحاد السعودي بالرياضه
للجميع حديث عن علاقته بالاستثمار واثر
قيمه ومبادئ على الشركات اللي يستثمر فيها
وكيف قدر يحول المعادله في الاستثمار
الجريء من خساره 80% من الصفقات اللي
تدخلها الى ان يربح 90% من الشركات اللي
يستثمر فيها وبحكم ان رئيس اتحاد الرياضه
للجميع
فهو حديث عن التحديات في السعوديه
وايش الوزاره اللي ممكن تساعد ان الرياضه
تصبح جزء من حياه سكان السعوديه
قبل ان نبدا هذه الحلقه فيها كثير من
النصائح كثير من التجارب وقصص لطيفه بشارك
الحلقه مع من تعتقد انها تهمه اما الان
الحلقه القديمه ايه بس مدري بارك كان في
لخبطت اللغه العربي انجليزي
نقدر نضبطها
انه عربي اغلبه اغلبه بحاول والله ما اقول
لك اذا سالتني
فيها كثير لكن رياض الجميع
كويس اي ما اشحن الا يمكن باليوم بالاسبوع
ممكن ثلاث مرات بس او مرتين اسكت والله بس
ما اتمرن فيه
ما يعطيني
المعلومات
بنبدا من الحين ما يعطيني المعلومات احسن
بكثير معلومات اكثر وش المعلومات
النوم تعطيني تفاصيل اكثر
[موسيقى]
في التمارين تعطيني تفاصيل اكثر للتمارين
من اسم الزون وينك في اذا كنت ثلاثين
بالمئه من اعلى
من 50% من 70% هذا الكلام اعطيني معلومات
اكثر حتى بالنوم خاصه اذا انا ما حبوب ما
احبها
انا استخدمتها شوي بس المشكله لما
لا لا
على حسب هذه
تميت منه صراحه ايام كوميد يوم بدا يوم 20
ونص وعشرين عشرين خلاص الوضع هنا مسكرين
علينا كل مكان خلاص اضطريت اني احاول اركز
على صحتي اكثر وركزت بالنوم اكثر
ست سبع ساعات
سبع سنين
[موسيقى]
وطريقه النوم ايش السرير اللي استخدم
المخده اللي استخدمها هذه مهمه يعني خلاص
بعدين اقدر اقدر اكون
عملي في في
الباديه تقول مقطعه ايه عرفتها زي اللي
يسوونها وش اسمها
[ضحك]
انك
كنت عايش على طريقه طريقه اللي الناس
تتوقعها منك مو الطريق اللي انت تبغى
تعيشها اوكي
وش الحياه اللي من هو خالد اللي كانوا
الناس يتوقعونه وكنت تحاول تعيشه والله
شوف اشتغلت مع الوالد المده طويله لمده
اربع خمس سنين
في المملكه في المملكه القديمه اللي على
طريق التخصصي
يعني مع ممارسه العمل معه طبعا ومع
الاحتكاك مع الناس المختلفه واحد يقول
خلاص اوكي هذا اللي بيصير بيمشي منطلق
ابوه ابوه ابوه فهذا المعيشه اللي او
البرنامج اللي كان في بالي انا خلاص لازم
تكون كلون منه مستنسخ منه
طبعا صعبه يعني في يعني زي ما تعرف في في
ستيف جوبز واحد في الحمد لله اللهم لك
الحمد بس الوالد واحد فيها فلان فلان واحد
صعب اني تكرر هذا الشيء لان انك تكون نفسك
فخلال الايام غير السنين الماضيه لما طلعت
من عند الوالد
وبديت عمليه بنفسي
مع شغل مع الوالد بس اكثر شيء كان الشغل
بنفسي اضطريت اني اقطع طريق انه يكون خالد
طريق خالد لما يكون طريق ان هل هذا يكون
متسخ من او مستنسخ من الوليد والحمد لله
مشت الحال في فتره كنت تبغى يعني مع
الضغوطات كنت تصير المستنسخ من الوريد كنت
ابغى بس كان بيكون الشكل خالد هذه ماما
طريقه حياه الوالد مختلفه ان حياتي انا
الوالد ما شاء الله ينام مثلا خمسه سته
الصباح يقوم الساعه عشره
11 نوم قليل جدا انا لازم انام 11 عشره
ونص انام اقوم الساعه 5:00 الصباح كويسه
لي انا
فهذه مثلا الموضوع وعد الموضوع الثاني
اللي انا اقول انه صار في
تطابق جدا مع الوالده هو العمل اللي هو
زي ما يقولون
الطريقه اللي انا اللي شفتها صرت احب
العمل واحب عملي
اشتغلت في البنك كرهت الوضع امور واحترامي
للجميع اللي يشتغل في البنك يعني ناشف
اشتغلت مع الوالد في في الاستثمارات
المتقدمه كويسه لكن ما كانت ما كانت
تجذبني زي ما يجذبني
الاستثمار الجديد
فلذلك اضطريت اني اخذ الاشياء اللي اقدر
اخذها من الوالده والحمد لله اطبقها في
حياتي العمليه
لكن بطريقه الخاصه والحمد لله مشيت الامور
يعني اللي الحين 11 12 سنه اشتغل في
راس المال الجريء وماشي الامور الحمد لله
يعني اتذكر ان خلال سبع ثمانيه سنين كنت
كنت اتكلم مع كثير من المستثمرين عن
استثمارات مختلفه وكانوا يقولون يا اخي
هذه خطره هذي مدري ايش لسه بدري عنها
والحمد لله يعني الان خلال 2018 والله
2016 شفنا تدفق اموال كثيره في القطاع هذا
خاصه والان الحمد لله صاروا الناس بالعكس
يجون يقولون لا ورونا كيف نقدر نستثمر في
هذا القطاع فالحمدة صار صار في نمو واضح
الان كنت في
بيت الاب في برنامج كان فيها معاليه
الوزير وزير الاستثمار وتكلم عن حجم
القطاع هذا في السعوديه الان وصل اكثر من
مليار دولار خلال 2022 الاستثمار الجديد
اكثر مني دولار فالحمد طبعا
قليل نسبه في العالم لكن الحمد لله النمو
اكثر من 72% من السنه اللي قبلها فالحمد
لله بدات الامور
حاولت اني استثمر 19 2020 و2021 22 الا
سعر الشركات عالي جدا
الشركات الثانيه تصب
لكن لكن الفلوس الاموال الذكيه مهمه من بس
الاموال تتدفق بس بس عشان تدعم القطع هذا
فيه
[موسيقى]
الاستثمارات المحليه لكن 2023 بدينا في في
انشاء مركز لنا في الرياض وفي دبي نقدر
نستقطب فيه
رواد اعمال عشان نسمع منهم ونقدر نستثمر
فيه في شركاتهم لانه مهم بس المشكله انا
مهم جدا اننا نتكلم مع رائد الاعمال انهم
ما يركزون بس في المجلس ما يركزون في
الشرق الاوسط لازم يركزون انهم يستخدمون
اموال خارجيه لان احنا نبغى ننشر ونبغى
نوري الشرط كيف حجم الاستثمارات اللي ممكن
تتواجد هنا مهمه
والاموال ذكيه موجوده هنا لكن لابد ان
واحد يكون مركز على اي شركه يستثمر فيها
واي قطاع مهم انا باجي على القطاعات
والاستثمار لاحقا شده يرجع
شخصيتك بحس ان في بعض التفاصيل حساب يعني
مثيره للاهتمام عندي يعني تغير نمط حياتك
اهتمامك بالقيم باهتمامك
احس قليل من الناس اللي يهتمون لمثل هذه
بودي اسولف معك اكثر فيها لاني انا مهتمه
لا لا لا اذا شفت الفيديو هذا لا جدا جدا
لكن كلها راحت
موجوده الحمد لله اي والله
ببدلها ثلاث شهور عشان لسه ما نزلت
بس تكفي
هنا ممكن تغيرت نمط حياتك
الى انه كذا يعني اقرب الى انه زاهد
ودي تحكين كيف كنت وكيف صرت
بعدين ابغى اعرف ليش سويت هذه الاشياء كيف
كنت كنت احب السيارات كنت احب
اول سياره يكون متواجده في يعني الاشياء
السطحيه اللي مالها مالها قيمه اطلاق من
الان لكن لما كنت اصغر مهتم بهذه الاشياء
بس الحمد لله لما كنت اصغر اتكلم عن عشرين
الى 25 وبعدين
[موسيقى]
ركزت في اني اركز باشياء اهم من كذا
وايش غير السيارات كنت
والله ترى يعني ما في اكثر من كذا
سيارات وكذا والحمد لله راحت
وبعتها
وركزت حتى في امور مثلا السباق سيارات
وصلت لدرجه اني اروح الحلبه لما كانت
موجوده وحلبات اخرى كنت اساعدك سيارات
ومدري لكن واضح انه
في السواق السيارات كذا وطبعا تطلع
بالنهايه تطلع وجهه تطلع بخسائر فادحه
فقلت لها يعني
بالنسبه اقتصاديا ما تعني لي ابدا فاضطريت
اني اغير طريقه تفكيري انه اني اركز اني
احط اموالي في اشياء
اهم واشياء تسعدني اكثر اشعه تسعدني اكثر
بدل بدل ما تكون السياره
تكون شركه مثلا حتى مو بلازم مثلا واحد
يحط ملايين في شركه ممكن يحط 50 عشره
دولار خمسين دولار مئه الف دولار في شركات
صغيره ناشئه وتقدر تشوف كيف تسوي لقيت هذا
يكون هذا المنطلق وهذا التفكير
اقتصادي اكثر لانه مدروس لكن
ممتع اكثر اقدر اتعرف على الشركات اتعرف
على القطاعات المختلفه تعرف على الرواد
العمال واقدر اتكلم معهم عن رؤيتهم في
المجتمع وعن انقطاعهم كيف حياثر هالمجتمع
وهو طبعا قطعهم قطاعهم كيف حينمي حينتمي
الى الى قطاعات اخرى في في المجال هذا
وكان يعني ممتع لي انا والله فاضطريت اني
اغير تفكيري من سيارات واشياء ما لها قيمه
الى اشياء لها قيمه مثل الشركات التخلص
منها السيارات بس
لا والله ما املك اي والله الى الامام لك
والله ايه
ما احتاج عرفت شلون الحمد لله يعني حتى
لما اكون ساكن في دبي يعني شيء شيء باجر
ماني قاعد اشتري شيء ما احتاج لان اشوف
انه اقدر اضخ هذه الاموال بشيء يستاهل
اكثر منا يكون اساس بيت مثلا اوكي القطاع
العقار عندنا في في دبي طبعا يرتفع
وبرتفاع مستمر لكن افضل ان انا استثمر فيه
اكثر من استثمانيه لنفسي لان البيت واحد
يبغى تبغى تنتمي فيه وانا ما ابغى انت مين
من مكاننا الان
موجود بالرياض موجود دبدوب بدبي موجود
متواجد برضه في
عند ما ابغى يكون عندي مكان واحد يقدر
اركز فيه وبرضو نتخلص من كل استثمراتك
اللي ضد البيئه مثلا موجوده
الحمد لله ولا شيء كان ضد البيئه لا شركه
واحده والحمد لله سبحان الله الحمد لله
اقول الحمد لله بس فلست ولا ولا كان لها
مردود جيد اطلاقا عكش بالعكس كنت مطالب
فيها والحمد لله لكن الاسكان اسمها ايجى
فلست راحت والحمد لله اني خلصنا منها
وعندي شركات لها دخل في
البيئه ضد البيئه
لكن شوف
ما في شركه تقدر تستثمر فيها لا يكون لها
علاقه في في شيء كما يقولون ضد البيئه
فما ممكن تلاقي اي شركه تكون مصادقه
البيئه مئه بالمئه فلذلك اذا احد فكر بهذا
الطريقه لن ينجح في هذه الدنيا لابد ان
يكون عندك
نظره شامله اكثر تقدر تكون مصادقه البيئه
الى اكثر الحدود لكن برضو انها ما تكون
مضره اي اكثر الحدود
وبرضو انت يعني تركت اللحوم وصرت وهذا
الكلام كلنا في اكثر من مره
والحمد لله ماشي اي والله طيب
اي والله العظيم جد والله
كلها على اللحم بس
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
وايش اللي خلاك تتغير يعني
ما اتكلم عن النباتي امجد من غيره لكن
اتكلم عن السيارات مثلا
تكون بشكل مدينه تبدا
لمن تكبر تشوف الاشياء اللي تهتم فيها
اكثر وايش عليها تميت فيها اكثر مثلا انه
ما يكون ما يكون
مادي بهالطريقه ابغى اكون انسان اقدر اعطي
اكثر ما اخذ
بالنسبه لي انا اذا اقدر اعطي الشركات
وقتي وراس مال
اذا كان في اكسبيرينس نوعا ما في خبره
بالاحرى بالنسبه لي اقدر اعطيهم اياها
تكون لي انا
اغلى منه يكون عندي بس امتلك اشياء ولذلك
خذيت هذا المنطلق الحمد لله زي ما قلت لك
سياره واحده تكفي الحمد لله
شركات الحمد لله نقدر نستثمر فيها بمبعد
الحدود ما عندنا صرخه قطاعات ما نستثمر
فيها يعني زي ما قلت لك القطاعات القطاعين
ممكن نقدر ما نستثمر فيها طبعا
ثلاث قطعات يعني
اللحوم ومشتقات
الحليب
عندك
لان كثير ناس ولا ولا حضيف قيمه لها
اطلاقا وطبعا
المسكرات والخمور وهذا الاشياء ما دخل
فيها والامور الثانيه الحمد لله ماشيين
بالطلاق فيها اي والله طيب في واحده من
مقاطع كمان طبعا حسابك
لا الحمد ترى أنا
ترى مو انا اللي اسوي كل هذا ما شاء الله
شركه الحمد لله كويسه جدا وعطيتها
السوشيال ميديا حقك ويتصرفوا انتوا يعني
انا زهقت والله العظيم اي والله كنت تقول
تغير سلوياتك في الحياه
زي ما قلت لك ماده
شوفوني كانت واحده من الاشياء اللي واحد
يبغى يفكر فيها وهو صغير يحسب انه لما انا
كنت صغير احسه من هذا الشيء اللي هو حيرفع
من مستواي طبعا
تعرف ان هذا الاشياء ما تعني شيء لكن
المطاف كلنا الدنيا بنفس الطريقه اللي
جينا فيها
ركزت اني حبيت اني اركز على نفسي اكثر ما
اركز على على تفكير الناس فيني
وممكن هذا يكون سلبي الى درجه ان ان الناس
ممكن تلاقي
اشياء تقدر
تنتقدني فيها ولا انتقاد مهم لي انا شو
يقولون عربي مثلا ليش ما تتكلم اكثر
بكلمات عربيه اكثر بالانجليزي ما يخالف صح
لكن للاسف للاسف دراستي كانت بالانجليزي
وعملي بالانجليزي اكثر الاوقات
استخدم الكلمات ومصطلحات الانجليزيه اكثر
في بعض الاحيان اكثر من العربيه مثلا هذه
ثانيا اطفالك لا عربي وانجليزي اثنين ما
شاء الله الحمد يتكلمون اثنين اي والله
ليش تلبس البوب ليش تستمر السعرات السلسال
مثلا ليش تلبسه هالكلام يعني نفسي انا
ماني عايش لك مو انت بس يعني ماني عايش لك
انا عايش لنفسي وعايش الطريق اللي انا
ابغاها ومرتاح فيها واشياء عندي اللي انا
فاضطريت اني افكر اقل من ايش الناس تفكر
وافكر اكثر هل انا قاعد اعيش حياتي
بالمستوى اللي ممكن
اني
اقدر اعطي مجتمعي ممكن اعطي عائلتي ممكن
اعطي اصدقائي اكثر من انا اقدر اخذ والحمد
لله هذا
الخط الفاصل احد لان في الاخير ما في كثير
ما في ما في نقطه واحده لانه صارت في ايام
مختلفه وصارت في سنين مختلفه لكن التغيير
الجذري صار صراحه ايام كوميد الجذر كان
قصدي برضو على اذا كل احد يقول انا بسويها
لان نفسي
[موسيقى]
باكثر مستوى تقدر تعيشه مثل النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم ما في اكثر من كذا غير كذا
كيف احد يقدر يتنقد فالعكس تنتقدني شكرا
وبعدين لما تطلع من هنا
ما لها معنى
يعني يكون عندك مبادئ وقيم تتماشى مع
مبادئ وقيم
مجتمعك وبرضه
ان تكون مبادئ وقيمت تعكس دينك غير كذا
ايش
تغيراتك المبادل اللي لما يكون في وحده من
الحركات كان يقول اذا ما عندك مبدا
ما حد بيزعل منك ايه فاللي عنده مبادئ ناس
بتزعل منه اللي يتغير برضو فيها شيء
بيخسرها وش الاشياء اللي خسرتها مع
التغييرات والله اي صداقه اي والله عندي
اصدقاء الحمد يعني اوكي الحمد لله بس عندي
اثنين يمكن
بس اقدر اقول اصدقاء لكن غير كذا خسرت
كثير وما اقول خسرت لكن اني بالعكس انا
اقول اني هم انكسبوه ولا كسبت انا كسبت
راحه البال وهم كسبوا انهم مرتاحه مني
بس هذه اللي ممكن يكون الشيء اللي ممكن
تكون خسرته
طبيعتي بطبيعتي وحداني يعني ما احب اي ما
احب اكون مع ناس ما احب اكون بمجتمعات ما
احب اكون بعشوات ولا هذا الكلام يعني
وخاصه مع اني نباتي ما حد يبغى يعزمني
والحمد لله ههه
بالعكس يعزموني يقولون والله ان رخيص
عازمتك الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
لاني
متيقن اني على الطريق الصح الحمد لله لما
تقول صدق وش تعريفك الصديق الصديق اللي
تقدر تكلمه
اخر الليل تقول له عندي مشكله ويقدر يقول
انا جايك بحل لك اياها انا عندي اثنين
ممكن اقول اذا كلمتهم يقول انا جايك الان
ونفس الشيء بالنسبه لي انا لهم هذا الكلام
يعني صديق انه يقدر يحط امور الشخصيه على
جنب انه يركز على على صداقتك وعلى العلاقه
اللي بينك وبينه وهذه وما اتوقع في ناس
كثيره اقدر
اسميهم اصدقائي بالنسبه لهذه الدرجه
وان شاء الله انا اكون
[موسيقى]
لهم زي ما هم لي انا
الواحد
لما يغير نفسه يبدا من نفسه ولا يغير من
اللي حوله واللي يغير كل شيء مع بعض
صعبه جدا لان طبيعه الانسان طبيعه الانسان
لازم يكون له
لازم يكون لها اوقات مختلفه خلال السنين
في في السنين الماضيه ممكن تقول انه يكون
له تغييرات مختلفه ما ممكن تغير بيوم
وليله يعني مثلا مثلا يعني
الحياه النباتيه اللي انا استمريت على
السمك لمده سنه سنه ونص الحليب ما احتمت
فيه ولا الجبن ولا الكلام لكن برضو بعدين
تخليت منها نفس الشيء مثلا بالنسبه لي
الانضباط مهم جدا فتعلمت هذا الشيء مثلا
خلال السنين الماضيه كنت اعرف انا الكلمه
هذه من الوالد كان يقول
انا اسوي كذا انا اسوي كذا كنت ما اعرف
ايش معناه هذا الكلمه الانضباط
ممكن تقول يعني اسف
كطبيعه الولد والابن يقول اوكي عرفنا
منضبط اوكي كنا سمعناها الف مره يا ابوي
خلاص عرفنا ثم
عشتها خلال السنين الماضيه وشفت
شفت طعمها وشفت نتيجتها في في حياه
الانسان
وهذا الشيء اللي يدعني اني اكمل على
المنطلق اللي انا فيه الانضباط ولا الشغف
هذا السؤال مره حلو والله العظيم
الشغف مهم لكن شغف ما حيكون عندك دائما
ايه لكن انضباط اذا كان عندك دائما تقدر
تبني منه الشغف
ومهمه هذه لان الانضباط تقدر تضبط نفسك
تقدر يعني ممكن انا اقول لك الان اليوم ما
اكل شيء اليوم بسوي كذا اليوم خلاص هو
تسويها لكن الشغف مو بدام يكون عندك شغف
تسوي شيء انا ابغى اتمرن ما عندي شغف كل
يوم
ساعتين وما تمرن اني تمرين بسيط
ومتعب واقول يا اخي ليش ابغى ليش ابغى
اسوي بنفسي اليوم كذا لكن الضباط مهم لانك
تقوم تقوم تقوم نفسك وتسوي هذا العمل حتى
لو ما تبغى تسويه نفس الشيء بالعمل
بالمكتب ابغى اكون في المكتب الساعه تسعه
ابغى كل المكتب الساعه ثمانيه بتكون
بالمكتب الساعه ثمانيه مو بس الانضباط بس
مو انه شغفا للعمل لكن انضباط عشان تسوي
تكون
مثال الى الموظفين الاخرين انه يشوفون انا
قاعد اسوي شيء انا قاعد اسوي هذا الشيء
انت تسوون هذا الشيء برضو انا اول واحد في
المكتب وانا اخر واحد في المكتب نفس الشيء
بس الانتباه مو سهل يعني جدا صعب لا جدا
صعب صعب وممل
ومتعب جسديا وعقليا لكن اذا خليتها عاده
ممكن تصير عاده ممكن عندك في كتاب انه
غلطان
ناسي شو اسمه بس اجيب لكم اسمه ان شاء
الله نقدر نكتبه في في
انك تقدر انه اذا اذا سويت عاده لمده 29
يوم او 28 يوم
ايوه
تقدر تبني هذا تصير عاده
فكر تبني بس المشكله فيها ان هذه 28 يوم
لازم تركز فيها
ركز فيها وتحاول فيها ممكن هي هالحلا
بتصير انضباضه تصير عاده
والانضباط يعني هو احتفل المزايا اتذكر
حتى فيها
كان يقول ان الانضباط هو العنصر الاساسي
اللي يخلي مؤسسي الشركات مؤسسه الشركات او
النجاح
واحده من العوامل المهمه للنجاح والانضباط
اكثر من الذكاء اكثر من الموهبه اكثر من
كل شيء والله اشارك نعم اوافق الراي
بالاحر
كل يوم اتمرن
تجي ايام ما تجيك ايام تقول
كنت مسافر امس وانا راجع سفرتنا الساعه
ثمانيه الصباح لازم اقوم الساعه سته فمتى
لازم متى اتمرن ايه فاضطريت اني اقوم
الساعه ثلاثه مثلا عشان اتمرن عشان ما
ابغى اقوم
سرير دافي غرفه بارده يعني
عشان ما تبغى تضيع عليهم يومك وتعرف
اذا سويت هذه العاده اللي انت منضبط فيها
بيكون فيه
يكون عندك عامل او هرمون الدوبامين عالي
انك تقول مبسوط في هذا اليوم كله او اكثر
بالاحرى
سمعت كم كلمه او كلمه كم مقال قريته واحده
منها اذا بديت يومك
وتخطيت امور صعبه في حياتك مثلا التمرين
كان صعب جدا
وتروشت بمويه بارده مثلا والكلام الامور
الثانيه تسهل بانه لانك بديت يومك بشيء
صعب وتغلبت عليه تقدر تخلص امور الثانيه
بسهوله حلو انك تبدا يومك هذا الطريق
يوم الطبيعي ابدا العاده كذا يمكن اقوم
الساعه سته سته ونص
اقوم بالتمرين سبعه ونص اخلص تسعه ونص
يوميا لا 6 ايام بالاسبوع
على اقل شيء
المهم انك اني الاقي اني اني اخلي يوم
راحه لان الشغف
مهم برضو
للتمرين ابغى اشتاق للتمرين
اذا ما تمرنت يوم تبغى تتمرن اليوم الثاني
عرفت فهذه يخليك تمرن اكثر واقوى اتوقع
بالنسبه لنا على الاقل ما اكل الين الساعه
خمسه
المغرب
وعندي مثلا
عصير من شركه اسمها هيول فيها كل
الفيتامينات
اللي يحتاجها في اليوم
واشربها خلال اليوم اشربها خلال ساعتين
ثلاثه لكن ابدا يومي انه كذا زي ما قلت لك
الا الساعه 9:30 الساعه عشره اكون في
المكتب الساعه خمسه اخلص
طبعا المكتب يكون الاتحاد في الرياض
للجميع هنا في الرياض
وبعدين يبدا العمل حق
امريكا تبدا تصحى كاليفورنيا وقت الساعه
خمسه عندنا فابدا شغل للرياده الاعمال
والاستثمارات اللي في القطاع الجري
[موسيقى]
ليش لان ابغى يكون في وقت لي انا
المهم اني اخذ وقتين اني اقرا اني اكون مع
عائلتي اكون
يمكن امشي شوي ولا الكلام اسوي شيء لنفسي
فهذا يومي بعدين انام الساعه 11:00 11:30
كذا واقوم نفس الشيء والروتين وللاسف بعض
الحين الروتين ممل لكن في بعض الناس مثلي
انا مهم جدا الروتين
اذا سافرت واذا كنت مثلا في جده ولا شيء
ولا وما كان عندي روتيني بمكان التمرين
والكلام شويه يلخبط البرنامج
المختلفه في الدمام في في جده كثير طبعا
دبي
متى ما اقدر الروتين يتغير ولازم اسوي
مختلف وتعودت على هذا الشيء وهذا يومي
والله وكل يوم مره
الاكل الساعه بين الساعه خمسه ولا الساعه
تسعه
خمسه تمر ثلاثه يعني ما في وجبه مع
العائله مش الساعه تسعه
لما انهم ياكلون بنات ياكلون المدخل بعض
الاحيان بس انا اكل عشائي الساعه سته وسته
ونص
هذه يعني وهذا روتيني وكل مره واحده في
اليوم
[ضحك]
طيب ممتاز والله يعني لان الواحد ايش اللي
يصير يعني ما تغيرات اللي تصير لما تسافر
انا اتذكر كذا احب الروتين بس اذا سافرت
ينعدم تماما حتى لو الاكل كل شيء لما
يختلف عنك وعن اللي انت تسويه تبدا تتغير
سواء حتى اجتماعات يمكن تكثر تقابل الناس
كثيره لكن المهم انك تحط اولويات الحياه
اسف المهم اني انا احطها اولويات الحياه
او
اني انام سته الى سبع ساعات في اليوم
اني اتمرن في هذا الوقت
واي وقت ثاني لكم وقت ثاني للمكتب وقت
ثاني للعمل وقت ثاني للاهل وهذا كان لكن
هذا وقتي انا مهم بالنسبه لي لكن ممكن
تسوي وانت ماشي والكلام سهل
تشتغل الان الحمد لله الحين
اثبت انه تقدر تشتغل من بيتك
تكون عندك عاليه فما عندك مشكله لكن
ان واحد يلوم
تغيير
تغيير الوقت وتغيير الحال وانا مسافر
وكلام يتلخبط لا تقدر
تستمر فيه
يعني عنصر مهم جدا واحده من الاشياء اللي
برضو في
فيديوهاتك تقولها متاكد عليها اللي هي انه
انك تعيش لغايه لهدف انه يكون في هذا
الهدف موجود دائما معك في كل قرارات
تتخذها وش الهدف اول شيء اللي انت والله
اني اعيش
اني اعطيت كل جهدي اني اخلي هذا الدنيا
افضل من كيف انا دخلت فيها طبعا هذا عام
ويعني اي احد يقدر يقوله لكن
لا بد اني اعيش هذه الطريقه لابني اني
اسوي هذه هذا هذا الهدف اني اعيش هذا بهذا
المنطلق
ولذلك اني انا مركز اني استثمر فيه في
شركات لها اثر قوي في هذه الدنيا
طبعا مو كل الشركات اللي انا استثمر فيها
لها اثر كبير كثير منها مالها اثر الا اثر
مادي
وبنفس الوقت ليس لها اثر سلبي في العالم
لكن في وحده اثر لها سلبي ولها الماده
منها علي جدا
عندك
كثيره
اذا بتركز على هذه بس
وبتنسى الثانيه يعني شوي
بس انها ايش اللي يصير لما تحط هدف سامي
وهدف انت تبغى فيه تجيك تحديات انك فرصه
انتبه وتقتنعسها لانها مغريه بس ما تتسق
معاه اهدافك ايش تسوي في هذه الحاله سواء
كانت فرصه هنا او حتى اشياء خارجه فيها
ابدا
اني انا اذا تركت شيء
واحد لوجه الله سبحانه وتعالى
سواء كان مثلا في في
تجاره الخمور في مثلا
القمار
مردود عالي صح يعني واحد يقول مين ما يقدر
يدخل فيها اذا انا تركتها الله سبحانه
وتعالى بيجيني افضل منها
طبعا انا ما اتكلم عن
القمار مثلا انه هذا الكلام الاستثمار
وهذا زي الاستثمار في في شركات
الغاز او شركات
النفط ولا كذا لا مختلفه جدا لكن هذه مئه
بالمئه ونعرف هذا الشيء تضر في البيئه
وانا وانا في بالي ان انا ابغى استثمر في
امور لا تظهر في البيئه والان شفنا لان
الحكومات مختلفه حكومتنا الحمد لله حكومات
مختلفه وشركات جدا كبيره قاعده تستثمر في
القطاع المستدام الطاقه المستدامه فالحمد
لله يعني الواحد مو محدود انه يستثمر في
شيء واحد لانه مردود عالي جدا في استمارات
مختلفه لها مردود عالي جدا
هذا الترف اللي هو اختيارات
يعني حنا في في مكان في التاريخ عندنا
[موسيقى]
عندنا الرفاهيه
في الاستثمارات في في قطاعات مختلفه جدا
فالحمد لله يعني الواحد مو محدود انه
يستثمر في شيء واحد
وفي قطاعات مختلفه جدا ممكن تنتمي من
قطاعات مختلفه مضره لكن تكون مجديه
للبيئه وهذا الشيء اللي يجذبني للاستثمار
فيه القطاع هذا القطاع الجري
اي نعم مهمه لان مهم الواحد يقدر يعبر عن
عن عن مشاعره سواء كان زي ما يقولون ولا
سواء كان واحد عاقل
طبعا يلا حلني تقول كلمه رول الحين ايش
كيف ترول
للعربيتكم فيها
صعب ان الواحد
يستبعد اهميه وجود شركه
[موسيقى]
تعطي القدره لاي احد يعبر عن مشاعره في في
موضوع واحد او عن شخص واحد او عن شركه
واحده المهمه لكن الطريقه اللي يستخدمونها
الناس للاسف
بشعه
فانا استبعد يعني انا ماني متواجد على
تويتر بالنسبه لي انا انا في شركه تتولى
هذا الشيء وكويسه اللي انا لان فيها راحت
بال احاول ادخل الى تويتر بعض الاحيان لكن
لسه برضه تشوف اشياء
[موسيقى]
مو كثير مهما تحمس كثير عرفت ولا تبغى
تسوي ميوت الالف واحد والكلامين صراحه
شغله عرفت
فتبغى تسمع من الناس
اذا كان اذا اعطاك فيدباك مو بناء ما ابغى
اسمع منه لكن ابغى اسمعه بالعكس اتعلم منه
التويتر مو مكان لاي شيء
قليل قليل والله للاسف هذه الحقيقه كله
لو واحد على الاقل انه يعرف مين هو قدامه
ولما تتكلم معي اقدر اعرف
اوكي انا اقدر اسمع منك وافهم منك حتى لو
كان رايك
كان رايك منه اوراق مو بنا وكان رايك
واقعي او واقعي الا اقدر اخذه واعطي معك
هناك ما تقدر تاخذ
لكن اكرر مهمه جدا وجودها مهم جدا في
الاجتماعيه بترتاح لها
اسهل
وانظف
والله اسهل بكثير والله مع اني ما ادخل
فيها كثير الان لكن اريح اشوفها وما فيها
يعني هذاك الهجوم اللي تلاقيه في تويتر
دخلت فيها بس ما عندي حساب اسمه ما سويت
ما فعلته
حتى سناب ما سويت في شيء المفروض اسوي فيه
شيء اكثر لان السناب عندنا يمكن احنا ثاني
وثالث اكبر دوله في العالم استخداما فودي
استخدمها ومهمه نستخدمها على الاقل اني
اعطي ارائي اسمع الناس لكن ما دخل فيها
طيب كيف تشوف تويتر بعد
مهمه جدا واحسن افضل افضل الف مره افضل من
الاول اللي هي والميه ليش انا لاني منحني
لليسار ولاليمين انا ابغى اسمع من الطرفين
ولما تشوف
حسابي في تويتر حتى حسابي بالانستقرام
اسمع من اليسار واسمع من اليمين وانا وانا
اقرر ايش قررت اللي انا ابغاها لكن تويتر
تطرفت بزياده باليسار
نعم السابق والان سمحوا كثير للناس
الموجودين المنحنيين شوي لليمين انهم يكون
لهم حسابات في في تويتر مفعله مهمه جدا
لانك لابد تسمع اراء الناس مهما كان اراء
[موسيقى]
لو اختلفت شركه مع قيامك يطلع منها
بالنسبه لايش مثلا اي قيام مدري يعني مثلا
متى صارت يعني مزعجه مثلا
انا انا ضد الواحد انه يبيع تبيع معلومات
بدون ما اعرف لكن هذا شغل
[موسيقى]
هذا شغل انه ببيع معلوماتك بدون ما تعرف
الى شركات عشان اخذ فيها
اكثر اكثر طريقه اكثر ربح ممكن
وسكرت عليه ابل بان لحين ممكن اني انا
اختار هل ارضع اني اعطي معلوماتي الى هذه
الشركه اذا حطيت لا وكثير ناس حطوا لا
شفنا
متى نزلت اكثر من عشره مليار مليار
يعني رقم مخيف
فهذه قيم مثلا انا ما رضى فيها لكن انا
برضو على انستجرام لانه مهم ان يكون فيها
وانا استمتع فيها واشوف يعني صراحه لو
تشوف لو تشوف اكثر الناس اللي انا اتابعهم
اكل طريقه طريقه طبخ كذا وطريقه طب كذا
والله بجربها اليوم بجربها يعني
مريحه
يعني
عرفت فحتى لو انهم ما تتماشى مع قيمة ما
حاترك الشركه لكن طبعا اذا صار فيها قيم
قيم دينيه قيم قيم اجتماعيه مثلا
يرضون على
انهم يدخل مثلا انهم يخلون الاطفال الاقل
من 13 يقول لهم حسابات وبدون مراقبه من
الاباء وكذا لا ما ارضى فيها يعني هذه في
قيم ما ممكن ارض فيها ولا ممكن ارضى ان
اهلي طبعا يدخلوا فيها لابد ان يكون في خط
على الاكل وهذه بيني وبينك تقول لي اي ما
حد يعرف
هل في وجبه يعني لو ما انت ابغى ارجع بس
سالت احد
اعرف من كم يوم هذا السؤال
قبل ما اقول لك الجواب هذا كنت فيه
وين كنت
من فتره
عندنا شركه اسمها
خلايا من السمك
يستزرعون شكرا اي والله اي والله دكتور
انهم ياخذون خليه من السمك
طبعا بدون اي هرمونات بدون اي كميروس بدون
اي
مضادات حيويه
في مناخ او مو مناخيه
في بيئه نظيفه جدا
[موسيقى]
المره الاولى بالضبط
طبعا لسه التكنولوجيا غاليه ولسه ما ممكن
تنزل للسوق الى خلال ممكن السنه الجايه
ممكن تشوفها بالسوق لكن ان الواحد العقل
يعني
انجنيت فيها لان طعمها السمك ريحتها هذه
السمك شكلها سم وهي فعلا سمك لكن هي بس
خليه من السمكه صار فيها من طريقه اخرى
ويقدرون يخلونها قطعه سمك قطعه لحم
بالاحرى
فجوابي على سؤالك ممكن اقول السمك بس يعني
هل اني ابغى اكله لا لكن المهم اني اعرف
انا وين جاء السمك يعني انا ما ابغى اكون
انا جزء من نظام
الصيد السمكه الان قاعد يصير في العالم
بناء في النظام القديم يسير في جميع في
اكثر الحال العالم غير مستدام وغير
انسان برضو
فما ابغى اكون انا جزء اني اعطي لهذه لهذا
ابعد عنه كيف تتخيل اغلب استثماراتك يعني
في مثل هذه المجالات سواء في
اللحوم وبدي اعرف كيف تتخيل البشر بياكلون
في 2050 شوف يعني وش طبيعه حياتك الموضوع
مو مساله انساني الموضوع مساله اقتصاديه
مئه بالمئه والله وانا اقول لك ليش
لاني ما ابغى اتكلم عن مواضيع الانسانيه
او مواضيع الاخلاقيه لانها ما لها معنى
وهذا الحقيقه
لن تغير في في نظام الناس ولذلك انا وقفت
اتكلم عن هذه عن عن التغيير في العادات من
هذا المنطلق لان ما فيها جدوى وعندك افضل
مثال واصغر مثال
[موسيقى]
فيه في المستشفى
الدكاتره اللي يشتغلون على
مرضى سرطان الرئه
وانا دخلت مستشفى
وكنت
الاماكن وشفتها بنفسي انزل تحت اطلع لما
اطلع من المستشفى الحمد لله مو بانام بس
المهم اطلع من المستشفى الاقي نفس الدكتور
يدخن اناظر اقول افكر بنفسي يا اخي انت
نفسك بعينك مو بعينك بيدك تشوف
[موسيقى]
المزارع الحيوانيه
اولا لازم تاخذ
عشرات الالاف من مساحه مساحه ارضيه لازم
تكون فيها
للحيوانات هذا واحد يعني الاستثمار او
الاكسبنس
[موسيقى]
الاراضي الاراضي
ثم لابد انها انك تاكلها ثم لابد انك
تشربها ثم لابد انك تداويها فلازم تحط
فيها 70% من مضادات الحيويه مباعه عالميا
تروح للحيوانات ما تروح للانسان 80% تروح
الحيوانات طبعا هذا تفكر انت قاعد تاكل
هذا الشيء اذا مو انت احنا كلنا نروح
للدكاتره والدكتور يقول انا بعطيه مضاد
حيوي تقول عندك شيء ثاني طيب تبغى اخر
الحل تبغى يكون مضاد حيوي ما تبغين اول
شيء تبغاه تبغى مناعتك تكون اقوى نفس
الشيء مع الحيوانات تاكلها اذا قاعد تاكل
المضادات الحيويه غير كذا طبعا لازم الله
يكرمكم بالغسيل بعدها يعني
هذا كله تلوث البيئه
نقلها من من المزارع الى
[موسيقى]
المسالخ
المسانخ كبيره جدا يعني عندك عشرات الالاف
متر مربع تكون تكون بس مسالخ فانت قاعد
تكلم عن شركه
تقدر
تقتصد فيها من هذا المنطلق اللي هو مثلا
مثلا حيكلف اكس الى الى انه ممكن يكلف 10%
او 20% من التكلفه ميل المياه حيسوونها
الشركات هذي هم لحالهم انتم مو لازم
متطالب فيها العالم كله
هينتقل من المزارع الحيوانيه الى مزارع
خلايا
ولا يشك بهذا الشيء اطلاقا حتكون مثلا
نفس المبدا من
الحصان كان كان يودينا من بوينتي الى
بوينتي الى السياره
الحين ممكن تركب حصان اذا تبغى هي ممكن
تاكل لحم من الحيوان اذا تبغى لكن
الاغلبيه حتكون متواجده المزارع
الخلويه زي ما يقولون
لانها اقتصاديا افضل والشركات هذه
منطلقه ربحي 100% الحيوان لها
شكل الحيوان لها بروتين مو شكلها ان حيوان
عرفت شلون انا ابغى كيف اقدر اطلع منتج
مستنتج من هذا الحيوان اكثر ما اقدر في
اقل وقت ممكن في اسرع وقت ممكن بغض النظر
عن ايش بيصير للبيئه يعني
من امازون قاعده تباد
للحيوانات
ولا قاعد يفكرون اطلاقا عن عن البيئه
برضو انا قاعد اتكلم عنها هذه اقتصاديه لا
يفكرون عنها للبيئه اذا اذا وديناه عندنا
مثلا شركه تايسون شركه كار جي بي سي لمن
غلطان في في
البرازيل من اكبر الشركات اللحوم في
العالم كلها استثمرت في قطاع
المزارع الخلويه ليش لانها
[موسيقى]
اقتصاديه اكثر وممكن اني اخذ خليه من
دجاجه واسوي فيها
صدر دجاجه في ثلاثه اسابيع احسن مني اخذ
دجاجه واربيها تصير عمرها الى ثمانيه تسعه
شهور
الوقت هذا مختلف كل فلوس بدنا اسالهم خلني
بس
تتحول الخليه الى
صدر يعني هل دجاجه واحده بتطلع لي عدد
معين من الصدور ولا لا لا خليه واحده مثلا
اذا كان عندك
ريشه طاحت من من الدجاجه او نقول الدجاجه
خذيت منها خليه الخليه تاخذها من ابره
صغيره جدا تاخذ بس خليه واحده من طبعا
دخليها كثيره منها تاخذ خليه واحده
تاخذ الخليه وتحطها في وسيط فيها
اللي موجوده اللي اللي تمثل
وجودها فيه
بطن الحيوان
والخليه هي نفسها تنتعش في السكريات اللي
تعطيها الجلوكوز اللي تعطيها البروتين
اللي تعطيها وتكبر بنفسها بحد ذاتها كيف
تكبر انها تضاعف تضاعف تضاعف تضاعفي لان
تصير حجم معين ثم تحطها في تحطها في
ايش مثلا يخلي هذا الجوال طريقته كذا مثلا
مو طويل
القالب صح نعم تحطها في هذا القالب انه
تحسين يطلع شكلها اللي تبغ
ثلاثه اسابيع تكون عندك هذه اللحمه وتقدر
تبيعها باسرع وقت بالنسبه للشركات هذا هذا
منتج من الخليه هذه كم اقدر اسوي للابد
خليه واحده اخذتها اقدر اسوي للابد للابد
طبعا للاحرى ما تبغى الا بد عشان في عمر
افتراضي ما تبغى
تاخذ خليه
فيعني يمديني اجيب بس دجاجه احب واحده
عندي في المصنع ابدال ملايين دجاج
وهذه تجيب لي ملايين مبيعات بس
بالنسبه للشركه هذه يعني
المساحه اللي
نعم المساحه بالنسبه لك تكون مثلا 95% من
المساله تحتاجها تقدر تستخدمها بس خمسه
بالمئه تستخدمها والباقي وش تبغى فيه
بالضبط يعني الموضوع اقتصادي بحث الموضوع
موضع انساني
وهذا ترى موجوده من الستينات ايه لانه
كانوا يزرعون اعضاء اعضاء للانسان والان
تطورت التكنولوجيا
للعضلات مو بس للاعضاء
اللي هي الخلايا الجذريه
لا لا عجيب والله يعني اقدر اخدم فطح ميه
بس مو بحقيقي
مثلا العظام موجوده
[ضحك]
لكن باقي موجود وتقدر تشيل منه كل الاضرار
اللي تجي منها لان احيانا الحيوان ممكن
يكون في بكتيريا في اشياء في بعضها ضاره
بس يعني ما سمعنا فيها مثلا ما سمعنا بس
سمعنا بارتفاع سعر البيض في امريكا ما
ادري اذا سمعت فيه ولا لا صار العين اذا
تسوي جوجل سيرش خلال الشهور الماضيه اللي
ما يعرف متى احنا قاعدين نصور جانيوري
ديسمبر 2022
حتى
نوفمبر 22 تشوف صور سوبر ماركت الاسواق
الايه حق الدجاج ما في او البيض ما في بيض
لانه في شورت تجيب البيض
لان صار فيه
حمى انتشرت بالنسبه في الدجاج
واضطروا انهم يبيدون يقتلون اكثر من مئات
الملايين من الدجاج عشان يقضون على هذا
اللي ممكن كان يطلع على فكره هذا موضوع
ثاني
وانقطعت البيض ارتفعت اسعارها
فهذه الامور تقدر تتوقف مئه بالمئه تقدر
تتوقف في في
المستقبل لان البيئه اللي موجود فيها
الحيوانات غير غير غير
صالحه اطلاقا يعني تشوف حتى الناس اللي
يشتغلون فيها لابسين الكمامات وما ادري
ليش لابسين عشان الريحه بس لا لانه فيها
فيها امراض قاعده تطلع ممكن تنتقل للانسان
هذا الموضوع خطا جدا طبعا عشناها الان
فيها في في كوفيد وممكن نعيشها ثاني مره
وكان في احتمال نعيشها ثاني مره
لولا
التخلقوا او تخلصوا من
عشرات الملايين من الدجاج
من الخلايا بتقنيه مختلفه تقييم مختلفه
ياخذون ياخذون البروتين من من النبات
من
[موسيقى]
البازلاء ياخذون البروتين منها بعدين
يحطون فيها مواد اخرى من النباتات ويحطون
فتصير
شرائح لحم ممتاز
في فتره طبعا
لذيذ جدا بس بس
ولولو وبيوتك
طيب الحين اذا افترضنا ان هذه اقتصاديه
ارخص الان مو اقتصاديه ارخص على فكره
ولذلك الان قاعد تشوف
السعر منخفض جدا جدا يمكن 90% من من وين
ما كان
سعر السوق نعم كان بيجي هنا سؤال يعني
الاكتتاب نزل والحين صار منخفض جدا سعر
السهم المستثمر
لا بعتمد على ارتفاع الحمد لله
لكن انا عندي نظام انا ما تقدر تحب الشركه
انك تقعد فيها للابد
بس ليش طاحت طيب اذا اذا هذا هو المستقبل
يعني
لازم ترجع الى الى الى
2018 2019 كان عندنا في في البنجر في
القطاع
الجريء كان عندنا شيء منطلق اسمه
باي طريقه باي تكلفه
حتى صار في كتب مختلفه فيها واحده من
اسمها
وكان يعطيك فكره مثلا
في هذا المنطلق
خذ كل ريال دولار ممكن يطلع من المبيعات
لك وحطه فيه
انك تنمي المبيعات اكثر ما تقدر اكثر من
اكثر من
الابتكار صح ولذلك شفنا ابتكار قليل جدا
خلال الثلاث سنين الماضيه وخاصه ايام
كوفيد ايام كوفيد
حكومه الامريكيه وحكومه اخرى طبعت اموال
وسلم الناس كثير
صار في سيوله كثير صحيح فصار في قوه
شرائيه اكثر لذلك
للاسف
من الحقيقه للاسف بياند ركزت على النمو
باي طريقه
استثمرت كل العوائد اللي ممكن تاخذها من
المبيعات الى انها تبيع اكثر وتبيع اكثر
في جغرافيات مختلفه في العالم ما
ركزت على
الابتكار
جاه نهايه 2022 صار فيه تقليص في في
القوه الشرائيه حكومه امريكيه رفعت النسبه
صار في برضو ضعف في القوه الشرائيه في في
العالم خاصه في امريكا
ولا لا يخفاك ان بياند اغلى
من الهمبرجر العادي اغلى يمكن
الناس صارت تقول ان انا ما ابغى ادفع هذا
البريميوم هذا المبلغ الى الى
بيانور ليش ولا ابغى استثمر ولا اسف ولا
ابغى ادفع مبالغ عاليه للحمل العالي
ابغى اللحم الاقل
فنزلت اسعار كلها ترى نزلت اسعار
اللحوم عامه لكن خاصه لان ما كان عندهم
العائد ما كان عندهم ما كان عندهم
احتياطي ما كان عنده بالاحتياطي الكافي
انهم يقدرون يركزون على
الابتكار ما كان عندهم الا همبرجر وثلاث
انواع
وحتى سووا شراكه مع بيبسي سووا
ما كان في استثمارات مهمه ما كان في قوه
شرائيه ولا كان في رغبه للناس تشتري لذلك
نزل السعر غير كذا في صحفيه من بلومبر
طبعا ما قصرت تكره هذا سبحان الله ترى هذا
هذا القطع يعني صراحه عدمت
وكل الشركات الثانيه بن تكتب بس اشياء
انتقادات
[موسيقى]
ولا تذكر اي شيء ممكن يكون ايجابي
وغير كذا
ما كان عندهم شركات اخرى ممكن انك تقارنها
فيها الطريقه الوحيده اللي ممكن تقارن
بيوند تقارنها باللحم العادي دائما حيكون
اغلى فلذلك دائما حيكون اسوا
بالمنطلق يعني سلاح ذو حدين واحد يقول لي
راحوا انهم سووا اكتتاب وكانوا اول شركه
تطرح في الناس هذا شيء كويس لكن مو كويس
لانه ما عندك شركات اخرى تقدر تقارني فيها
عرفت شلون واذا في شركات اخرى تقارني فيه
حتقارنني فيها
مطروحه
فنزل سعرها الى الان 17 دولار 16 دولار
وعندهم مشكله والله ما يخفاك عنده مشكله
كبيره واذا ما حلوها ممكن الشركه تروح مئه
بالمئه فهو مو بس لسوء القطاع ومستقبل
التقنيه سوق الشركه وادارتها مئه بالمئه
سوق اداره 100% سوق اداره الان شوف
المبيعات مرتفعه ليه واحد استمرت في انها
تكون شركه خاصه مو شركه عامه واثنين
كلهم الابتكار
بس انتشر باي طريقه وطبعا شراكتهم مع
الاقل ساعدت كثير
طيب هذا بالنسبه للاكل
يعني واضح مثلا انه ممكن بعدين يكون اغلب
الناس تاكل اكل من
خلايا او من بعض التقنيات اللي زي كذا
اللي هي اللحوم ياكلونها تخيل
[ضحك]
بجده في وش اسمه
[موسيقى]
وبيزعل مني اني زعلت والله العظيم
في جده وهنا في مكان اسمه
نباتيه اكشن والله كويسه اي والله العظيم
بس مشكلته ما يحطون فيها بطاطا يعني غريبه
العاده تاكلها من اول ايام الصاج الذهبيه
كان فيها
اثقل شوي لكن لا فيه موجوده انت محروق من
النوم ماما
نوره كنت احب الصاج ذهبي وكنت احب اللي
على التخصي شايف شو اسمه
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
شو العلاقه مثلا بالحليب الاطفال وهذه
حليب الاطفال نفس الشيء طبعا تقدر تاخذه
عن نسيت اقول الشركه هذه برضو تقدر تاخذ
خلايا من الانسان من الام وتسوي حليب
انسان حليب ام حليب منه حليب ناس انسان
ممكن تعطيه الى الاطفال الرضع او الامهات
اللي ما يقدرون يرضعون اطفالهم او من
الاطفال
الخدج السوبر ما يكون مثلا
ابو سبع شهور يكون خمس شهور و4 شهور هذول
اللي يقدرون يعيشون الان طبعا في
انفارمت مره مره مختلف لكن المشكله ان
اكلهم يكون مختلف جدا لانه قاعد ياكلونهم
حليب بقر وحليب كذا ولا يكون مطابق الى
النعم لذلك
يكبرون في يكون عندهم مشاكل معويه كبيره
وتستمر حياتهم هذه تحل المشاكل مثلا تحل
المشاكل مئه بالمئه طيب
للحيوانات يعني من الشركات تريد تدخل فيها
ايوه انها تخلي الحيوانات ياكلون نباتي
ايه فهمت عليك
شركه تسوي
استزراع خلوي وبرضو تسوي
بالعربي صعب
زي ما تسوي مثلا البيره اللي غير اللي ما
فيها كحول كيف طريقه انه واحد يسوي البئر
او يسوي الجبنه مثلا تقدر تسوي نفس الشيء
في طريقه تكنولوجيا تقدر تسوي فيها بروتين
وتقرا تسوي فيها اكل تسوي منها اكل
للحيوانات مثلا
هذه تحل اي مشكله انت تقولي طيب ليش قاعد
تسوي كذا
عندك شركات
كثيره في
نطاق
الاكل
للبسس والكلاب
قاعد يكون فيها امراض مختلفه
يكون فيها
[موسيقى]
استدعاء لهذا المنتج لانه فيه امراض ممكن
نسبب مشاكل الحيوانات الاليفه هذي تحل
المشاكل هذي مثلا فما يكون في اي شيء
امراض ممكن تستنتج من هذه من الطريقه اللي
يجمعوا فيها
اكل للكلاب والبسس هذي تحل المشكله هذي
طبعا في شركه ثانيه مختلفه اخرى
هل فيها هل لها مستقبل من جد واعد هل هي
حتحل مشكله واضحه موجوده في هذا العالم
هل اقبال الناس فيها
عالي
طبعا
العلاقه بيني وبين
[موسيقى]
مدير الشركه او المؤسس هل العلاقه كويسه
هل اقدر انا اشوف
مرئيات المستقبل هل علاقتي انا متطابقه
معها يعني هذه اشياء مهمه
اللي بيعطيني فلوس
في فلوس كثيره
بس الحمد لله يجونا الحمد لله الحمد لله
مكان من غيري انا لكن الحمد لله بالنسبه
للقطاع هذه الحمد لله ترى الناس صارت تجي
للسعوديه تطلب استثمارات من شركه سعوديه
زي كابي دبلي وهذا شيء يشرفني وبالعكس
عشان اوريه ان السعوديه مو بس فلوس بس على
بلاش
افضل استثمارك دخلت
والله
الحمد لله دخلنا فيها على على 16 ويعني
بينها بمبلغ عالي الحمد لله ولا الحمد لله
قاعدين نحاول نسوي معاهم
[موسيقى]
في طرق مختلفه لاني نقدر نشتغل معاهم لكن
مهمه كانت وانا اشوف انا في شركه ثانيه
بتكون اكبر منها لكن والله الحمد لله اسوء
واحده منهم هذه واحده منه الشركات
[موسيقى]
في لحظه
بعدين انا استغربت فيها والله اي والله
استغربتها وقتها في كوفيد ايام كوفيد في
شركه كانت تملكها شركه اللي تسويها
فورتنايتروا شركه
اذا انت جيمر ما اعرف والله العظيم لكن
المسامعين اللي يعرفون عن الجيمنج عندك
نلاقي اللي ممكن يصير مثلا اذا احد قاعد
يلعب لعبه مثل فورتنايت وضغط زر الوقت انك
تضغط الزر ويكون فيه
حركه في
اللعبه هذا مهم جدا هذا اذا احد كان يلعب
كان يلعب في في
بطولات تعني الكثير فهذه الشركه سوت
تكنولوجي انها تقلل هذا هذا
الانتظار او هذا الرقم الى الرقم جدا
منخفض يعني لا شيء عجيب طبعا انا في بالي
وفي بالي
وناس كثير اللي استثمروا فيها قلنا هذه
شركه عظيمه وهذه من جد حتوصل الاماكن
عاليه
واثباتا عن ذلك شركههم
فاستثمرنا فيها لكن كان في مشاكل بين
[موسيقى]
محاكم فيها وراحت الشركه للاسف اي والله
ماتت وشركه طبعا انشرت من شركه ثانيه يمكن
20 فلس للدولار يعني مره بس للاسف ماتت
لكن هذا واحده من الاسفل الاستثمارات
توقعت ان تكون عائد جدا عالي لانها ممكن
تكون
تكنولوجيا هذه ممكن تطرح لي
كول اوف ديوتي لاي العاب مختلفه اخرى لكن
ماتت للاسف بتغير اللعبه اي نعم بس لا
والله راحت ايوه طبعا وعلى فكره السعوديه
كانت تجربه الاولى لهم كانت مثلا البنج
يسمونه
في فورت نايت كان مثلا عشرين
بالعربي
لا والله
عشرين عشرين جزء من الثانيه بعد الشركه
هذه صارت صارت فاصله
خمسه.2 جدا انخفضت
وكانت اول تجربه لهم بالسعوديه وناجحه جدا
كانت لكن للاسف والله كانت خساره وراحت
يعني انه الخساره اكثر من الربح لكن تجي
وحده صفقه مو دائما هذه حلاوتها مو دائما
الطريقه اللي احنا نستثمر فيها مختلفه جدا
من الطريقه
في القطاع الجري
عندنا شركه اسمها
هذه الشركه تاخذ
احقيه الاستثمار احقيه
الاستمرار في الاستثمار في الشركات
الناجحه
للشركات
البنجر
صناديق الاستثمار مثلا عند انت عندك شركه
او عندك محفظه وانت تبغى تستثمر فيه شركته
شركته الان
[ضحك]
تبغى تستثمر بشركته شركه مثلا عندك انت
مثلا عشره مليون تبغى تدخليها وتدخل فيها
بعشر مليون لك الحق اسمها لك الحق انك
تستثمر
وتخلي
النسبه حقتك مستمره على هذا على هذا
الرقم في السنمرات اخرى لك الحق انك تحط
فلوس اكثر ولا هيروح عليك هذه الاستثمار
لان ليش اذا انت استثمرت بعدين قعدت بعدين
الشركات ثانيه استثمر استثمرات راس المال
يرتفع
قيمه استثمارك هتقل تقل تقل لكن لسه الرقم
مثلا موجود لكن لا يمثل 10%
من من شركته يمثل 5% الان عشان
طرح اكتتاب اخر
بس انت ما تقدر تستثمر ليش
عندك الان ما عندك فلوس كفايه تقدر
تستمر فيها تجي لي انا تقول استثمر لي انا
انا اقول لك اوكي انا بستثمر لك بشركات
اللي انت تبغى تستثمر فيها لكن انا بعطيك
50% من العادي انا انا الان حمستك انك
تعطيني انت افضل الشركات اللي انت تبغى
تستثمر فيها بس ما تقدر
لاي لاي سبب
وقلنا صراحه نسبه الخسائر الخسائر صارت
العاده
يقولون عشرين
بالمئه خساره 20% ترجع كل راس المال واكثر
الحمد لله عندنا الان يعني اختلفت جدا اني
صارت عشره تسعين عشر بالمئه خساره 90%
الحمد لله ناجحه ما شاء الله
الانضباط مهم انا كثير شركات جتني وقلت
والله حلوه حلوه حلوه وديتها الى الى
الرئيس الاستثمار عندنا قلت ايش رايك بهذه
الشركه قال مسوي الهمبر حقها وشاف انه هل
في شركات ثانيه تبغى تستمر فيها هل عندهم
شركات لسه يبغون يستمرون من الماضي يبغون
يستونوا فيها لا نبعد عنها
كثير منهم خسروا والحمد لله يعني ما شفنا
فيها اي اي مشاكل لحظه
ما شاء الله عليها لكن
[موسيقى]
شركه سيارات كهربائيه شركه
بس انها تشبه يعني تسلي لحد كبير في حد
كبير انها الكترونيه
راحت علي من ست سنين سبع سنين اي والله
ايوه راحت علينا لكن يلا الحمد لله
الحين اتكلم في عشرين
ما اقدر اقول انه ما راح تضبط يعني
بالنسبه لي انا في بالي شركه كهرباء بتكون
ضد تسلا شركه جديده بعدين شركه بس
ما كان عندهم
لا ما ظنيت انك تنجح وقلت يعني صراحه يعني
عبد اللطيف جميل ما كان عندهم هذاك
الباكره انهم يستثمرون في القطاع هذا
والله ما ابغى ادخل فيها ولا ادخل فيها
والله سبحان الله راحت
كانت يمكن 200 300 مليون
[ضحك]
بس
الحمد لله
يعني فيها هذه السنه هي سنه
فهل هي سنه الذكاء الاصطناعي مثل ما كانت
سنه
الماضيه قبلها كانت سنه
فهي هبه وتمشي ولا هي تشوفها فعلا بتغير
شكل العالم شوف مكان الاي اي مختلف جدا من
الميتافيرس مختلف جدا عن الانفتي للاسف
اللي خرب علينا نفسيه
الطريقه اللي كانوا يستثمرون فيها الناس
التكنولوجيا
اسف حقك انا نفسي مهمه جدا وهذا شيء انا
انا خلفه لمن استثمر فيه لكن خلفه وادعمه
اذا كان في طريقه لكن ما في طريقه الان
اشوفها اقدر ادعى اقدر استثمر فيها لكن
خربت عليهم البورد والكرامه الفاضي هذا
هذا عدم عدم شيء اسمه نفتيز
بالنسبه
لسمعه
متى اللي خربتها متى نفسها
للاسف انه يدخل بشيء واحد يقول هذا خربان
يعني للاسف لانه سمعته زفت
باع معلومات المفروض ما يبيعها وفي طريقه
اشتغلت فيها فيسبوك للاسف ما كانت نظيفه
اترك هذا الموضوع على جنب متى ما اشوفها
بتكون اي شيء مهم
للثلاثه اربعه خمسه سنين الجايه لان
الواحد
[موسيقى]
صار عندي اربع ساعات وخمسه وخمسين دقيقه
اقدر اسوي فيها شيء ثاني ترقص فيها
تقدر تستخدمها بطريقه تكون استنتجيه اكثر
الوقت تكون استثمار افضل لوقتك من انك انك
تضيع وقتك تكتب شيء لمده خمس ساعات اقدر
اخلي يكتبها بعدين انا اقدر اغير فيها
حاليا انا وفرت مثلا ثلاث ساعات ونص اقدر
اسوي فيها شيء ثاني في وقتي اكثر من اني
اضيع وقتي اقدر اكتب شيء عندي مثال جدا
مضحك ويمكن لهم مكان مضحك لكن مضحك لي انا
فالاتحاد السعودي لهذا الجميع ارسلت ايميل
الى رؤساء
الاقسام اللي عندنا يمكن 5 6
السبجكت كان
اعطني كم طريقه كيف اقدر استبدلك بالعيال
وبعدين تحت مكتوب
الانشن شديت انتباهك بغير المعنى الاول
الان وريني كيف تقدر انت تكون
كيف تكون
وقتك تستثمر افضل باستخدام العياري لان
العيايوي ما حيستبدلك حيساعدك
وعندهم الان مثلا
ابريل خمسه
يقدر يحسن في وقتهم
في الفيديوز مثلا في كتابه المحتوى كل هذه
الاشياء
والان صارت واضحه مع انه صار الوضع اوكي
ياليت موجود ايام المدارس حقنا اقدر اشوفه
بس راحت علي لكن بناتنا وعيالنا كلهم يعني
حياه ثانيه الان حياه ما قلت مهما حاولت
ومهما جربت تقول لهم لا لا تستخدمه ولا
بيستخدمون المياه ليش لان انا بستخدمها لو
انا
بعمرهم الان مهم
وزارات مثلا وزاره وزاره التعليم تعرف كيف
تغير منهج او طريقه التعليم فيها في
بلادنا وفي العالم عامه انا اتكلم عن
بلادي الحفظ ما صار له قيمه اطلاقا
انك تكتب تكتب خمس خمس صفحات مقالاتك هذا
ما له قيمه اطلاقا الان لازم تعرف معنى
المحتوى ليش كتبت كذا
ايش الفكره خلف هذه خلف هذا المقاله
[موسيقى]
وحلول مختلفه فلذلك الان وقت مهم بيكون
جذري
انك تغير طريقه التعليم في في في اي في
المناهج في العالم خاصه في بلادنا اي
والله بس
يعني في اكثر من شيء يخوف يعني مثلا هل
الوزارات التعليم سواء
الذكاء الاصطناعي ان تغيره اسرع من قدره
صحيح الحكومه على انها صح تبدا تتغير صح
فهذا مخيف مره يعني ومو بس كذا هل احنا
مستعدين الان
باننا نستخدم ونعرف قوه
قوه الذكاء الاصطناعي
يعني بالنسبه لي انا انا كنت مستغرب من
اننا ننزل بهذا السرعه
انا كنت افكر جوجل جوجل
عجيب صحيح الان جي بي تي يعني من جد حينقل
الناس من من
مكاني لمكان اخر بسرعه ما انا متعودين
عليها ايه وهذي اللي هي احسنت تخوف يعني
انت تقول قبل شي انه ما راح يستبدلك لانها
اتوقع انه يستبدلك بالراحه يعني على حسب
على حسب المدير
الحاسب المدير انا بالنسبه لي مئه بالمئه
اقدر اقدر اقول عندي 37 موظف الان في
اتحاد السعودي للجميع اقدر احطهم عشره
واقدر اعلمهم على عالم
بمختلف هذا شغلنا الان لكن
مهمه انك تعرف انك واحد عشان تكون ليدر
مثالي
لابد انك مو بس تخلي 37 تنمي 37 انهم
يتعلمون كيف يقدرون
يستثمرون وقتهم بطريقه افضل يستخدمون فيها
العياري ولكن
ميه بالميه ممكن انك تستبدلهم او ممكن
تعلمها عشان يكون انهم اكثر بس في الاخير
انت يعني زي ما كنت تقول على النباتيه
والمنتجات الجديده اللي هو الاقتصاد هو
اللي اذا في فلوس شركه كل الشركات وتبدا
تبحث عن هي كيف تقدر توفر فلوسك فاذا
الذكاء الاصطناعي بيخلي
يعني معظم الوظائف اليوم ما عاد لها قيمه
فجاه الناس يعني بيطلعون من وظائفهم
بسهوله وتشوفها احس اثرها بيكون على الدول
غير دول الخليج
الا لان ما عندنا صناعات كثيره فمثلا تخيف
الصين يكون عندهم كم مليون مزارع كذا
تشيله كذا مليون عاطل فجاه وهذا ما عاد
يعرف شيء يعني هو مزارع ما عاد يقدر يصير
شيء ثاني يعني
ما تدري شو تسوي فيهم صدق ما ادري كيف
بيصير بشكل عالم بالنسبه للمذاعه انا عارف
ان هذا مثال عام لكن المزارع مستحيل انهم
يستبدلون المزارعين لانهم مربوطين في
الاقتصاد زي امريكا زي هنا في في السعوديه
مجبورين احنا اننا ندعم هذا القطاع وندعم
المزارعين لان عاده
وما تقدر تدور ظهرك الى الى ناس
صعبه هذا تسير المز لكن مثلا خل نروح مثال
ثاني
مئه بالمئه يعني الشركات التكاسي استراحه
صار واحد يقدر يكون هو بنفسه اوفر وهو
يمضي بعد فتره تصير مئه بالمئه لكن ايش
سويت صار في قطاع ثاني
من الناس الناس صارت لها دخل ثاني من اوبر
مثلا اوبر لحين واحد يكون يشتغل في هنا في
البودكاست بالليل اقدر اشتغل واسوي او
اكون انا اوبر فصار فيه اندستوري ثاني صار
في ماركت ثاني نفس الشيء في اتوقع
حيستبدل الناس لكن الناس حتلاقي حلول
مختلفه او طريقه مختلفه يقدرون على
اوقاتهم انهم تخلي الاي اي اي او الذكاء
الاصطناعي يساعدهم بنفس الوقت
ممكن تندثر ويصير صعب انه الحكومه فمثلا
بدل ما يصير الدعم بالمزارعين انه خلاص ما
عاد اقدر صدقا انا تخيل اني ادم ج الذكاء
الاصطناعي مع
قدرات شو اسمه روبوت حق المايتي
تخيل اثنين يصيروا مع بعض يعني شيء مذهل
يعني الانسان مئه بالمئه
الدعم يصير انه نعطي يعني فاللي هو ايش
يسمونه
الضمان الاجتماعي بصير
سؤال جيد والله العظيم شوف
اظن مع السنين الجايه هذي مع الخمسه سبعه
سنين الجايه هذي حيكون في تغيير جذري في
طريقه المعامله معامله الناس مع الذكاء
الاصطناعي وطريقه معامله الحكومات مع
الناس اللي انا اشوف انه ممكن يكون في
بطاله عاليه اقل البطاله العاليه ممكن
تصير ليش لان
رؤساء الشركات ورؤساء المؤسسات هذه ممكن
يشوفون ان الدولار اهم من تواجد الناس او
او العمل مع الناس هذا شيء هذا الراس مال
وما تقدر تغيره تقدر تغيره لكن ما تبغى
تكون زيي دول ثانيه
[موسيقى]
فهل هذا هذا حيجبر الناس انهم انهم
يخترعون
نطاقات اخرى
[موسيقى]
ماركت اسواق اخرى تساعدهم في خلق وظائف
جديده لان انا ما اشوف ان الوضع انه كله
ان العالم حتنتهي عشان العيال بالعكس انا
اشوف بالنسبه لي انا اشوفها اكثر اشوف انه
حينمي قدرات الناس انهم يستثمروا وقتهم
بطريقه احسن هذا وجهه نظري انا
بلوكتين
للاسف اول ما واحد يقول في بالي يحط باله
على طول بيتكوين واثيريوم
لكن
مهمه انها تكنولوجيا التكنولوجيا نفس الحد
ذاتها مهم بس
هذه التكنولوجيات صار فيها
غيمه
سوداء ليش لان شفنا النزول الحادي اللي
صار فيه
والان صار الناس يتفهمون ان البروتين
متعامل مع هبوط حاد
وبتكوين واثيريوم ولا يفكرون ان البوكسين
ممكن تكون مهمه الى شركات تقدر تسوي نظام
واحد مستدم انظمه مستدامه وانظمه شفافه
غير قابله للغش والخداع والكلام فمهمه جدا
لكن للاسف
تفكير الواحد صار محدود
يعني ما اتكلم عن عن البيتكوين بحد ذاته
اتكلم عن التكنولوجي عامه حق
وهذا متواجد يعني مثلا اذا انت انا قلت لك
اوكي عندك الان بعطيك 100,000 دولار ابغاك
تشتري فيها ذهب
تروح تحطها في البنك تقول البنك ابغى
اشتري ذهب بتمسك الذهب ما حيجيك البنك
بيقول لك الا عندك ذهب بس ما عندك ذهب ما
تعرف حتى لو قلت ابغاها بيدي ما حيعطونك
اياها
الذهب ليش له قيمه قيمه
1300 ولا ما اعرف والله كم قيمتها الان
لكن ليش لها قيمه الان لان الانس لان
المارك لان الناس تقول ان هذا قيمتها الان
البيتكوين ليش قيمتها 19000 عشرين
الف دولار البيتكوين واحد لان الناس تقول
هذه قيمتها لما يفقد الناس
الثقه في
البيتكوين هذا الوقت حيصير في انهيار
حتى العملات الحاليه مو بس العملات ينطبق
على البنوك
نفس الشيء نتكلم فيها لكن شوف السيليكون
بنك
حقته ممتازه
المانج متحقه رائع
اخر مشكلته سبحان الله مشكلته اخر سنتين
صار عنده ودائع ثلاث اضعاف اللي كانت
عندهم 2019 اكثر من اكثر من 190 الى 220
مليار دولار لكن يعرف ايش يسوي فيها لازم
لما تاخذ وطمن الفائده كانت منخفضه جدا
ساضطر انهم يسوون شيء استثمروا سيليكون
فالي بنك بالوداع اللي عندهم
في شي اسمه
2018 اسف 2008 2007 هذه اللي سببت
الانهيار العالمي اللي صار طبعا
صار فيه انهيار عالمي من اول ليه لان كان
في تلاعب
كان في تلاعب كان يبيعون
السكيورتيز اللي ما لها قيمه في قيمه اعلى
طبعا ثاني مره للقيمه اعلى واعلى واعلى
الين ما صار قيمتها لا تعني القيمه
الشرائيه حقتها ولذلك
لكن شروا هذه هذا السكيوريتي اسمها
طبعا في بال الناس ان هذا عائد جيد واحد
ونص بالمئه
لكن تفكيرهم
انهارو من 2007 2006
فصار في تفكير هذا طبعا الان ارتفع نسبه
الفائده
السند اللي ثمنه
اذا كان يعطي واحد ونصف بالمئه صار الان
يعطي 45% قيمه السند اللي يعطي واحد صار
اقل فاضطر انه يبيع جزء كبير من المئتين
مليار من الوداع هذه السند هذا بخساره
المليارين غسلت مليارين
اضطروا على غيرها انهم يدفعون
للودائع اربعه خمسه بالمئه صار في شورتج
ثلاثه بالمئه وين بجيب ثلاثه بالمئه على
على
200 مليار وبجيب لهذه فاضطر انهم يرفعون
راس المال وانهم يبيعون جزء من الشركه من
البنك واضطر انهم يسوون طرق مختلفه ما عاد
ما حادخل فيها الان لكن اضطروا انهم يسوون
بطريقه طرق مختلفه
انهم يدخلون فلوس للبنك عشان تكبر عشان في
في انخفاض صار طبعا هذا خوف الناس
لما تقرا الجرائد
ايران
ايش معناته البنك انا اقول لك طلعت فلوسكم
البنك ترى في مشكله هناك انت تقول طلعت
فلوسك ولا انت تقول لسانه
الناس يسحبون ودائعهم تسحبوا دعائهم
الوداعة هذه هي اصول الشركه وصول البنك
طبعا انا ما اقدر اقول لك ما تقدر تاخذها
انا بستثمر فلوسك كداع لكن انت لك الحق
داخلها فلوسك هذه المطاف
في العالم فجاه الناس تسحب كل فلوسهم
بيفلس 49 مليار في خلال يومين
سحبت خلال يومين لذلك
اعجبك اسمها الان لذلك المؤسسه الفدراليه
للتامين على الودائع في كاليفورنيا استولت
على البنك وقفلت كل السحب والاستلام منها
لانه قاعد يسحبون بطريقه مخيفه
طبعا ما ساعد
سوق
الاسهم حقهم انهم نزل اكثر من 60 70% في
يوم واحد
فاصار في صار في انهيار انهيار من من شتى
الاماكن وليش دخل بس الموضوع جيد
يعني العجيب في البنك انه ما هو يعني ما
كان انهيار لسوء لا لا اداره ولا كان
احتيال بالضبط لم يكن احتيال لم يكن سوء
اداره وما فيه انهيار للسيستم عامه في
البنك الحين الناس خايفه لا ما في ما في
نظام بالبنك مستمر جيد لكن المشكله صراحه
حتى التايمنج حقتهم لما لما قالوا انهم
يبغون ياخذون يبغون مليارين من السوق و500
مليون من شركه استثماريه
نفس الوقت
اللي فلست اعلنت افلاسها
اعلن اعلان واحد يقول سيلفر واحده من اكبر
الشركات الكاب فلست والان اكبر شركه في
اكفر بنك 26 اكبر بنك في امريكا واكبر بنك
في
سوق البنجر كافه في كاليفورنيا قاعد يطلب
فلوس
هم لهم خمسين بالمئه من شركات الناشئه
والفنجه موجوده في العالم في البنك هذا
لحاله
فلذلك
مؤسسه الفيدراليلي لتامين الودائع لابد
انه مو بس تستولي عليها لابد انها خلال 48
ساعه جايه الى 72 ساعه لابد انها
تسوي تسوي الى كل الودائع لان الناس اللي
تقدر تسحب ودائعها وتحطه
او تصير مصيبه كبرى مصيبه او امريكا ما
تتحمل مصيبه هذه خاصه الان انت ما تتكلم
عن بنك صغير ما تتكلم عن بنوك
الصغيره في في ارزونا اول شيء لا تتكلم عن
بنك
[موسيقى]
متواجده هذه البنوك مما تعجبك في المناطق
شيء ثاني هل هي داعمه للقطاع هذا زي ما
كانت السيليكون فالي بنك تدعم القطاع هذا
لا
يعني لو تسالني انا انا اتوقع ان خلال 72
ساعه الجايه ممكن تلاقي
بنك كبير يستولي على سيليكون
والفنج الفيدرالي يقول انت لك لك الحريه
مثلا 50 مليار
50 مليار
انه ما يكون عندك الضمان الضمان ضمان علي
انا بشغلوا البنك زي ما صار
فانا اتوقع هذا الشيء يصير واتمنى هذا
الشيء يصير انهم يشترونهم شركه او بنك خاص
وخاصه تمشي الامور لان ممكن تصير كارثه
اذا لم يتصرف البنك الفيدرالي بطريقه
سريعه مش بياثر على الشركات الناشئه
الرواتب الحين مثلا شاري واحده من الشركات
على فكره واحده بس الحمد لله
ما عندها القدره انها تدفع رواتب 13
كلها في البنك
لذلك
احنا وشركات اخرى
نتكلم مع الشركات ايش تحتاجون ونعطيهم
مثلا قروض
قليله المدى او قصيره المدى بالاحرى بدون
فائده طبعا عشان تحل مشكله
وهذه طبعا كل هذه مسؤوليه على كل
شركه مناشيه اسف على كل محفظه وشركه لاي
شركه لها دخل في هذا
السوق لابد ان لها مسؤوليه انها تدافع عن
شركات الصغيره هذه راس مالك في واحده من
المسؤوليات اللي تذكرها زمان
انك الشركات
من
تخلي سعوديين يشتغلوا فيها ويتدربون عندها
او انك تجيبهم وش اللي حصل من هذاك الوقت
صار كثير والحمد لله عندنا شركه الام
متواجده لحين هنا
[موسيقى]
في الحليب الرضع
عندنا واحده اسمها
برضو هنا شركه اصلا من
من الخليج
تسوي كاميرا 360 درجه مثلا في
البوكسينج اللي صار
تقدر تشوفه كانك هناك اذا كنت لابس فيار
الحكم ممكن يلبسه مباشر والحكم ممكن يكون
لابسه مثلا وين ما يروح الحكم انت تكون
تشوف
نظريه الحكم
عندنا شركات ثانيه مثل
[موسيقى]
موجودين هنا الان توقعوا مع قطر
باذن الله قريب انهم يوقعون هنا عشان نبغى
نسوي شراكه معاهم ومع
جامعه الملك عبد العزيز جامع الملك عبد
الله
التقنيه لما اسوي فيها تبادل معلومات
الحمد لله ماشيه الامور هذه المهم والله
العظيم يعني اذا ما اعطي اذا ما اعطي شيء
الى الى الى الى وطني
ومهم اني اخذ
التفكير والاكسبيرنس اللي عندهم واجبه هنا
لان
متعطش المنطقه لهذه الاشياء
طيب
المره
الرياض كان
الشهر الماضي
كيف كانت التجربه
اترجم التجربه الثانيه كانت جدا ممتازه
الحمد لله
الريح بكثير من تجربه الاولى
لكن
ضاعفنا
المشاركين والله عارف ان المشاركين من
عشره الاف الى 15 الف وطرينا نوقف كان في
اكثر من زوجي لكن
المسار ما كان افضل مسار يعني انه ماخذوا
اللفه مرتين في نفس على نفس المكان
مشكله في تحديد
واحنا مربوطين بهذا الشيء
لان نبغى نبغى نسويه مثلا في وادي حنيفه
نبغى نمر في الدرعيه لكن زي ما تعرف في
اشغال في الدرعيه
عشان في مسار الرياضي
فلما يفتحون حيكون
المراثون افضل بكثير لكن احسن شيء نقدر
نسويه الان انهم يلفون مرتين عشان مره ثوم
كامل
لكن التجربه الحمد لله جدا جيده الحمد لله
كان متعاونين معنا الحمد لله الدفاع
المدني المرور
امانه الرياض
كلها الحمد لله صار في تعاون طبعا وزاره
الرياضه كلهم متعودين معنا لابعد الحدود
عشان
ناس من اكثر من 120 دوله اي والله
السنه الماضيه معتمد نعم مو بس كذا حلاوته
انه سبحان الله يعني هذا شيء جميل جدا صار
في مقال في
[موسيقى]
مقال في جريده في كنز سيتي
تكلم عن
امراه مريضه الله يشفيها ان شاء الله كانت
فيها السرطان
كانت تبغى تركض فيه الرياض وسوت كل هذا بس
عشان تجي تركض مره ثانيه الرياض وكتبوا
عنها انه كيف كان تجربه جيده وتجربه
والحمد لله مره كويسه وما كان في مشاكل
للمراه ولها كل هذه الامور الحمد كانت
يعني هذا شيء يعني يعني يحلو كثير فانا
نبغى نشوف اشياء
ايجابيه اكثر من الغرب او الشرق او ضرب بس
نبغى اشوف اشياء ايجابيه اكثر بنسب بلادنا
والله العظيم المهم اننا ننشر هذه الاشياء
اي والله كويس الاقبال اللي فيه واحس انه
الناس تبغى تسوي رياضه ناس تبغى تجري بس
بس
لا تزال السعوديه يعني ناقصه هذا البنيه
التحتيه اللي تساعد الناس تمشي يعني امس
كذا كنت في سالفه مع واحد من اصدقاء يعني
الشباب ارسبن مجلس فيهم فهم يقول لي
تعالوا
ما ابغى اركب سياره
روح عشرين دقيقه عشان اجري فودي اذا انا
ابغى اجري ولا ابغى امشي ولا بمارس اي
رياضه والدنيا نسويها وانا من اي مكان
اطلع اطلع من المكتب ولا اطلع من البيت
اسف اقولها مستحيل تصير الان في الرياض
ليش لان البنيه تحتيه الموجوده في الرياض
لا تساعد
ان الاحد يقدر يركض برا في الحاره مثلا
لان ما فيه مرصفه في الشارع وفي بيت ما في
مكان محدد للركب فخطر فانا بالنسبه لي انا
رئيس اتحاد الرياضي للجميع اقول لك لا
تركض في الحاره لانه خطر
لكن لسه الناس يسوون هذا الشيء
في اماكن لازم تروح لها للاسف طبعا الان
صار في تغيير بالنسبه
القرويه الان
غيرت في نظام نظام
المشاه فلا بد ان يكون في مكان للمشاه في
الضواحي الجديده الجديده القديمه صعبه
تسويها صعب
طرق صغيره اصلا اذا تحط طريق المشاه خلاص
ما عاد في طريق للسيارات فلذلك انا قاعد
اقول لك انه صعب جدا انه تكون متواجده
لكن للاسف زي ما قلت لك
المهم لنا نحن ندف الناس للاراده انها
تطلع انا عارف من عشرين بالمئه عشرين
دقيقه كثير لكن لازم تسويها عشان ما في
طريقه ثانيه الا اكثر من انك تروح نادي
طيب ماذا عن
بيكون مسار للدراجات في الشارع يعني هذا
هذا نبغى اسويه مثلا في وادي حنيفه والان
شغالين الان مع مع هي الدرعيه مع هيئه
هيئه الرياض مدينه الرياض من بعد
انس بن مالك مثلا
ولا صعب لا لا مو صعب
لازم الدرعيه قصدي اغلب الطرق يعني اي
اغرب نبغى نسويها لكن اقل لازم تكون
لازم نشتغل مع وزاره البلديه وزاره
البلديه عندها عندها اولويات اكثر من تحط
طريق للسياكل مثلا للاسف طبعا الحوادث
كثيره يعني عشان ما في مكان للسياكل بس
فتلاقي يعني في حوادث للاسف فيها لذلك انا
اقول اختاروا الاماكن الافضل
الاماكن
اللي تكون
سيفر انه تكون امن لكم
ويعني اي احد يقدر يسوي رياضه باي مكان
صراحه لكن لابد انها تكون بطريقه
مدروسه شوي لانها صراحه عندك سيارات
المشكله يعني
خصمك سياره مو خصمك انسان ثاني بالسياره
يلا يلا السلامه
طريق الملك عبد العزيز عبد العزيز
جنوب في المسار الاحمر اللي حق
الحافلات سيارات
لا لا حشره الاف عشرين ألف حط 5000 ما
يهمني حط نظام قوي ضد هذه الاشياء نفس
الشيء اذا كان في نظام
للدراجات اذا كان في دراجات لابد انه تحط
نظام يحمي الدراجات
لان خطر
[موسيقى]
عندنا شغل كثير وصعب الشغل لهذا الشيء
وانا اشوف انه نقدر نخلي السعوديه اكثر
حركه ونشاط لكن لابد ان يكون في تعاون
مستمر بين الاتحاد السعودي
اللي تمثل وزاره الرياضه ووزارات اخرى زي
وزاره التعليم زي وزاره
التعليم
اقول لك اياها بس زي الوزاره التعليم
ووزاره
ليش البدء والاسكان
التعليم مهم جدا ليه لان
الرياضه مو مفروضه على
البنات لسه مو مفروضه في في ممكن تكون
مفروضه لكن مفروضه من المفروض
حنا نبغى تكون مفروضه نكون نكون متواجده
فيها واحنا نقدر نساعد فيها
البرامج لهم انا عارف انهم صعبه ليه لان
لابد انك توظف ناس جداد اللي هم خبره في
الرياضه نقدر نقدر نعلمهم نقدر نسوي احنا
تدريب لهم عندنا برامج في الوزاره في
وزاره الرياضه التي تمثل فيها اتحاد
السعودي للجميع
عندنا برامج لتدريب المدربين انهم يدربون
الطلاب
الاثنين وهذا شيء بيرفع معدل الحركه في
البلد بشكل عالي جدا لكن لابد اننا نشتغل
مع بعض فيها هو ارتفع الرقم ولا الحمد لله
ارتفع يعني في في 2020 طلعنا الى 53
53% من المجتمع يتحرك يمارس الرياضه
مهم جدا السؤال هذا غيرنا احنا المعنى
الان لكن كان المعنى 30 دقيقه في الاسبوع
اسبوع اقدر انا اقعد اسوي كذا واجيبها
تصدقني سهله جدا لكن انا تحديت الفريق
وتحديت
نفسي
وتكلمت مع الامير عبد العزيز بن تركي ان
نبغى نرفعها الى معدل نفس معدل
مؤسسه الصحه العالميه اللي هو 150 دقيقه
بالاسبوع حوالي 30 دقيقه باليوم حوالي
والاصغر من 18
ستين دقيقه في اليوم
هذا له دخل في المدارس اذا حطيتها في
المدارس خلاص انحل هذه المشكله اللي انا
الان لازم اركز على الكبار
او النار
الحمد لله
جانا اوكي سوينا سوينا دراسه وارسلناها
الى الى نهايه الخبره وارسلناها الى الى
الى
الديوان
من طريق وزاره الرياضه والحمد لله جتنا
الموافقه خلال الثلاث ايام الماضيه ان
الان تعريف الحركه في الرياضه اللي هو 150
دقيقه في اليوم هذا صعب جدا
وهذا مش انا بنقص الرقم بس جدا لكن انا ما
ابغى شيء سهل
يعني الحمد لله التحدي صعب الحين ينزل
الرقم لكن الان نزل ترى على فكره الى 48
ومع هذا التعريف الجديد ممكن ينزل الى الى
فوق الثلاثينات يعني ما حينزل كثير
لكن حينزل اكثر اذا ما كان في استمرار في
في مبادراتنا وفي برامجنا في في الاتحاد
لا بدكم تستمراريه والله يعجل من
المسار الرياضي حديقه الملك سلمان
ومثل هذه المشاريع مئه بالمئه وشفت لقاء
برضو الامين الرياض
معرض عدد الحدائق العامه الموجوده في
الاحياء
انتم مستهدف
بحس هذي كلها ممكن تساعد يعني بدونها
والله ولا شيء عندنا برنامج مثلا مع
الوزاره
البلديه نفعل هذا سويناها في عصير سويناها
في الدمام
نفعل حدائق عامه هناك بدل ما تكون موجود
فيها ملاعب ولا فيها شيء احنا ندرب اهل
الحي النمو هم يصيرون مدربين فبدال ما
احنا انت تدفع انك يكون عندك راتب الى احد
يقدر يجرب الناس تخلي الحي هو مسؤول عنها
والحمد لله يعني نجحت كثير وبرنامج اكبر
اهميه انه صراحه وصراحه مهم كان الى
برنامج جوده التحيه
اللي هو تفعيل المدارس
بعد اوقات المدارس يعني بعد ساعتين او
ثلاثه حرام عندهم منشاه
ما تحرك من بين الساعه 4:00 العصر الى
الساعه سته الصباح يوم الثاني
في ملاعب فيها كل شيء يعني لو تشوفه والله
جيده جدا مره تصطيبات من هنا لكن سهله
وزاره وزاره التعليم
اعطتنا الحقيه اننا نتصرف فيه 13
منها في السعوديه الحمد لله هذا المهم
اللي انا برضو على فكره انا ما اسوي شيء
بس بالرياض ايه
ولا في المدن الكبيره يعني مو بس جده
والدماغ الرياض عندنا في
تبوك في عرعر في في حائل في
[موسيقى]
مدن اخرى صغيره لكن
فعلناها 13 صار عندنا اكثر من الغلطان 100
الف مشترك
اي نعم
والان ارتفعت الى 48 هذه السنه بس السنه
الجايه قالوا نبغى 72 قلت لا ابغى اكثر من
شوي شوي انا ما ابغى شوي شوي يعني انا انا
قطعه خاصه ابغى اشتغل بكره
[موسيقى]
مثلا اذا وصلنا مثلا 500 ولا شيء
الحمد لله وهذا شيء ممتاز ان نقدر نخليه
هذه مسؤوليه مجتمعيه غير انها مسؤوليه
اتحاديه
تصير هي الحالات اللي اكتشفت ان السعوديين
يحبونها انا استغربت والله العظيم يعني
اكيد الكره رقم واحد لكن السباحه كانت
عاليه كره السله طبعا كانت عاليه السله
قاعده ترتفع
اكبر اكبر واحده للمشي اعلى احلى وحده
اكثر اكثر من اكثر من الكوره
عندك كبار يسوون هذه الرياض ومهمه جدا
وانا برضو ابغى اسوي مثلا برنامج ما
سويناه وقائمه في الدراسه في مخي مو للاحد
ثاني لكن ابغى اسوي مثلا انا شراكه مع
وزاره
اللي ماسكه المساجد
الاسلاميه ابغى اسويها بالمساجد مثلا اذا
كان فيه مشي في المساجد واحد يمشي حول
المسجد مع الامام ولا شيء هذه اشياء مهمه
طيب تمشي للمسجد وترجع طبعا هذا مشي يعتبر
مره مهم يعني مره مهم تفعيل دول المسجد
يعني ما يبغى بس دوره محصور بوقت الصلاه
ويقف بالضبط انا ما ابغى اشوف كذا ابغى
اكون حركه اكثر بين السرايا يكون فيها
اشياء ممكن تصير جوا ممتاز وقعنا مع
المؤسسه العالميه للرياضه للجميع بس ما
تفيسه
وعندهم كل اربع سنين زي الاولمبيات
للرياضه للجميع
وفي سلوفينيا السنه الماضيه فزنا في في
موافقه في استضافه هذه الالعاب في الرياض
وحتصير باذن الله ب 2028
ويعني هذا الموضوع كبير
محصور
بمعناه يعني هذا رياضه للجميع ليس
للولومبيات ليست
اكسبو 2020
على حجمنا لكن كبيره على حجم الحمد لله
الله يعطيكم العافيه والله طيب رمضان هل
تشوفها موسم ممكن تفعيل من خلاله
اشياء تخلي الناس تمارس رياضه رمضان اسهل
سبحان الله اسهل شهر ممكن نتمارس فيه
الرياضه او تقدر او اسف تقدر تحث الناس
الممارسه الرياضه لان طبيعه رمضان الواحد
يقول انه كان انا فاضي انسان فاضي ما
حيكون عنده وقت
اوكي ما ابغى اتكلم مع برمضان اتكلم مع
بعد رمضان ما ابغى الاجتماع يشير الان فسر
ناس افضل فهذه بالنسبه لي تكون
انك تتعامل مع الناس انك تحث الناس
للرياضه وطبعا انواع الرياضه مو شرط
الواحد يكون
كروسفت بالرياضه لا بين رابط المشي نركض
قبل قبل الفطور مهمه وجدنا سهله
هذه العاده هذه مهمه جدا والكوره وطائره
صح فهذه كلها قاعدين نستثمر فيها
وماشيه في برامجها الحمد لله الله يعطيكم
اي والله طيب الحين بدات بجانب شخصيه برجع
اجانب شخصي طيب
الانضباط تعلمت منه فنون الاستثمار
وش اللي تعلمته من الوالده الله يرحمها
من الوالده
لسه لسه صعبه
الصبر
ايه مره
اسف مره بموقف موقف موقف صعب فيك ايام
جوجل
تعلمت منها الصبر تعلمت منها
[موسيقى]
الايجابيه
تحملت فاكثر شيء توكل على الله سبحانه
وتعالى
باي شيء صعب ممكن يصير في حياتك
توكل على الله سبحانه وتعالى مهم جدا
وكانت
كانت كثير
تعلمنا هذا الشيء يعني كانت اصعب اصعب
اوقاتها كانت دائما تقول وكل الله حتى
يعني باصعب موقف كان فيها بحياتها طبعا في
اخر السنه باخر السنه في حياتها صعب جدا
لكن الصبر
الشغف في العمل الجدي
توكل على الله سبحانه وتعالى في معنى
الكلمه
الابتسامه في وجه الغريب
يعني ما في احد سبحان الله سبحان ما اقول
لك صراحه ما في احد ما اقول عشان الوالده
حبيبتي الله يرحمها لكن اقولها فعلا
الكلمه انها كانت فعلا تبتسم في وجه اي
احد وما في احد الا كان يقول انه يبتسم
لها كانت جاده في العمل وكانت شديده بعض
الاحيان لكن ما في احد الا يحبها سبحان
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين وطبعا شهاده
هذه المجروحه امي لكن هذه الاشياء اللي
تعلمتها منها
ايه اسف اكثر الوالده ولا الوالده
يقولون الوالده انا يقولون الوالده اكثر
فما اعرف والله
طيب
تحس نفسك اقرب منك مواطن ولا امير
لا والله شوف انا دائما احد يسميني اي شيء
انا خالد
ما افكر اني اسمي نفسي امير وهالكلام
نهايه المطاف في الالقاب تيجي بتروح ولا
حتغير
في شخصيتي من انا وهذا برضو ثاني تعلمته
من الوالده يعني الحمد لله حبيبتي هي كانت
فعلا بنت الملك سعود لكن ما كان انها
تعايشه عيشه كانت عايشه على طريقتها طبعا
عمري 18
و16 زي كذا
وكانت عايشه بطريقه يعني تحمد الله سبحانه
وتعالى على كل حال ما قلنا كانت مسكينه
وفقيره ولا شي الحمد لله ربي منعم عليها
لكن ما كانت برضه
عايشه بحياتي الرفاهيه والكلام فهذا الشيء
اللي تعلمته منه صراحه يعني الواحد انه
يكون قنوع باللي عنده حتى لو تقدر يكون
عندك
السيارات يكون عندك بيوت وخرابيط هذه ممكن
واحد انه ترضى بس باللي عندك مقنوع باللي
عندك واستثمر وقتك واموالك باشياء
تستاهلها اكثر من لاعب بس هباء المنثوره
تروح
فلا هذه انا ما اعتبر نفسي الا خالد حتى
يسميني اقول له خالد ابو جنى يعني اي
واحده من الثنتين
يعني
بالنسبه للناس انه امير هو جاء شيء ايجابي
وش الشي يسبي من الجانب الامريكي ايجابي
وله سلبي هو فعلا شيء ممكن ممكن
مثلا
في كتاب الامير عبدالله مساعد كان يقول ان
البنوك كانوا معي
ما يدينونه لان امير صح يعني
انا بغيت اسوي محفظه محفظه
اصدقاء وانا سنينه الجماعه عشان ناخذ يكون
عندنا محفظه استثماريه قلت محفظه
لكن
الهدف مو من كذا الهدف انه انه احتاجه هذا
الشيء لان نبغى نسوي محفظه يا جماعه
مستثمرين وكذا لا ما تحتاج شكرا
طبعا هذا الوقت وقتها من زمان طبعا الان
سهله الان انا تقدر تلاقيها بس مو عشانك
امير ذويها ويكون يعاملونك معامله
اي شخص اخر وهو المفروض ان اي شخص اخر هو
انت بالمعنى بهذا المعنى
صحيح هذا الكلام صار من اول انا اتوقع انه
نعم اوافق الامير عبد الله لكن الان لا
الان يعملون اي احد معامله انسان ثاني
واذا كان
لابد يكون عندك وصول تحطها هالكلام عشان
تاخذ قروض من الكلام
لكن يعني اشياء سلبيه الاخرى اني صراحه
الاشياء سلبيه اللي ممكن اشوفها ان واحد
يقول اوكي مثلا كنت برا يقول اوكي هذا
اميره اكيد
نفسها او خلاص شبعان او اوكي ما يبغى
يشتغل قاعد وكسلان
لا الحمد لله اني قاعدين نشوف هذه العاده
مو العاده هذه هذا التفكير مو منطلق ابدا
في في اي احد يكون سواء الامير وموامير شو
الامير عبد العزيز
يعني مو ملزم انه يكون وزير الرياضه يعني
بشوف مو ملزم انه ينام سته سبعه الصباح
يشتغل مو ملزم انه يتعب ويكرف على على
مثلا اللي عنده لكن يسويها ليه شغف وحب
المكان اللي فيه نفس الشيء لايحه ثاني ايه
اذا كان عندك شغف وحب للمكان اللي انت فيه
حيث حتادي سواء كنت تعمير وموامير لما
تكون
ولد لواحد من
اغنى اغنياء العالم
وش اللي فاكر انك تشتغل
[موسيقى]
الطريقه تربيت فيها الوالد الوالده كلهم
كلهم قالوا خلي يكون عندك شيء ملموس تتركه
في الدنيا مو شرط تترك لنا تركته ايه
يعني فتح عيوني للاشياء اللي انا اقدر
اسويها في هذه الدنيا فلذلك
مو بس قبلت تشرفت اني اكون رئيس الاتحاد
الرياضي الجميع يعني ثمان سبع ثمان ساعات
في اليوم ماله مردود مادي اطلاقا لكن ابدا
صفر لكن لكن شغف لحب لهذه اللي انا فيه
والله قاعد اشوف نفسي واقول لكم ايش قاعد
اسوي يشوفوني لا
يعني هذا التربيه اللي تعلمتها من الوالد
الوالده يعني اترك اترك مكانك في هذه
الدنيا لما تترك
مكاني اني اقدر اعطيه البلد اكثر ما اقدر
بالنسبه للاستثمارات بالنسبه للشركات
بالنسبه لاني اقدر حتى اضعف احتمال اني
اقدر
[موسيقى]
اعطي شيء ايجابي الى صحه انسان ان يقدر
انصحه عن طريقه طريقه الحياه وما في اكثر
من نقدر شوي من طريقه الاتحاد السعودي
اكثر من ابوي
ما منها فائده ابغى اقوم ابغى اشتغل ابغى
اسوي هذه اللي علمني الوالد والوالده
الصراحه
الله يعطيك العافيه الله يطول عمرك حبيب
قلبي الله يوفقك شكرا والله شكرا لكم شكرا
لترك القحطاني والاء الحاج في الاعداد وفي
التصوير موسى وفيها تحرير محمد نور شمت
وفي الهندسه الصوتيه محمد الحسن وفي اداره
محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نوره السبيعي
والتلوين عبد المجيد العطاس واداره
التحرير اسيل الباب عبد الله هذا فنجان
احد منتجات شركه اماني لل نشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الانتاج بحب من مدينه الرياض
الاسبوع المقبل القاكم
شكرا
[ضحك]
ساعدتني والله
ساعدتني والله بيطلع فيها
الله يعطيك العافيه
عشان اجرب
كيف انك
يعني صعب
عادي عادي
وهنا في اثنين بس
بسمه
مره لكن في مرض مطاعم اخرى تلاقيها ولا في
جاهز تحط بيجن
بس الدمام
مع اصدقائك انت احسن مني كلهم
هو احسن مني بكثير ومؤدب
بس
تكلمت فيها لما يعزموني اقول اوكي بس
تبوله وحمص والباقي
يقول ليش ما يصير مثلا يعني
كانت سنه تقريبا بس كانت مرهقه صعب
اذا تاكل اكثر يكون اريح لك عشان لازم
بس انا ايه بس انا عندي كانت في المطعم
هاشم كل شيء يطلب منه
ايه اطلب منه فلافل ولا حمص تبوله سلطه ما
في شيء لازم هذه مشكله لازم
لذلك انا 90% اكل والله العظيم واتعلم ايش
اسوي بالاكل وبعدين اسويها
لان اذا انت متى متعود تقول لا جمعيه
جامعات اهل ما اروح لا والله وغلط ما اقول
لك انا صح علي بس ما اروح
[ضحك]
عرفت
او تروح وتسمع تسمع وحتسمع صدقني